meet Robert Irwin bindi Irwin 's younger
brother who's currently living in LA
with his mom teri while bindi competes
on Dancing with the Stars the 11-year
old told ET he's already acclimating to
life in the States
well in Australia we literally live
inside of zoo so we we've grown up in a
zoo and every morning we wake up to the
sound of Tigers roaring and lemurs
screeching and it's such an incredible
experience but here in LA there's
actually also a lot of wildlife so we
have the hummingbirds which has been
coming onto over Anders and we found
woodpeckers squirrels so it's not quite
Tigers but it's still a lot of fun you
being on camera in the audience is
causing a little bit of you know a stir
in the young ladies out there the young
girl watching the show they're like wow
he's so cute on this you know there
that's the reaction that's what their
boss is out there what's your reaction
to that hot really well thank you very
much but I'm a lot more interested in
wildlife at the moment I much rather
more very much rather go over and hug a
crocodile so but if there are young
ladies that are into paleontology that's
your best shot that's your best shot
okay I should go he'll be sad is that
the way into Roberts heart that is the
way into all the top if you love
dinosaurs if you love photography
how's that mountain by mountain biking
yeah yeah passes the old stream no
Robert was only two when his father
Steve Irwin passed away bindi and Terry
keep his memory alive with home movies
for us as a family we always tell
stories and we watch dad DVDs and mum
was so kind to take so many her movies
so we have all of these home movies
is that we watch and it's it's those
memories that just mean the most and
it's focusing on all the happiness and
good times that we had and that we
shared as a family but we're also very
lucky because oh through all of dads
amazing documentaries we we basically
have our life on on TV so all we have to
do is put the DVD in the DVD in the DVD
player and rewind and press play and
then we can relive these amazing
memories so we are very very lucky in
that respect